[Music]
so rude how close your hand is to my
face
also were you saying like don't
interrupt me is that what that was
yeah well yeah here it comes so
[ __ ] rude dude if i just close your
mouth like this and tan him no or or
lollipop
mr takemay yeah i know well now we got
to explain it okay so go ahead that's
the great thing to explain mr takame was
a guy a japanese man who taught spanish
very funny in high school in high school
now we're not saying oh look all walks
of life all races can teach whatever the
[ __ ] they want equal opportunity we're
all about inclusion but look dude mr
takemay was a japanese guy
see it's good to bring up dude he's a
japanese guy i probably talked about
this all my pockets at some point but
just the this japanese guy who [ __ ]
he taught like japan he's a thick accent
oh yeah yeah he would say uh he yeah i
mean he would say welcome
i mean like it was a tradition like a
japanese and you would be like
yeah and we were like it was very and i
remember once so confusing and i
remember one time he was like these kid
the bad kids came in class and they
smelled of like drugs and [ __ ] and
alcohol and he was going ah
[Laughter]
but he would go what was the thing yeah
he would be right yeah when you were
talking no you would go
oh look at his watch or whatever right
okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he would do that with his mouth though
okay
over
here
it was just a human walker that's right
that's right after he didn't even go
dude he was a human walking why would he
go ch
because he was a human walkie-talkie
okay human walkie-talkie that's it mr
tech made the human walkie-talkie that
sounds like a [ __ ] uh movie that
what's his name who did isle of dogs
would do
oh wes anderson yeah wes sanderson would
do that uh uh mr taymay is that isle of
dogs yeah mr takemay
the what is it the human wakataki would
be made by the guy who did the [ __ ]
stop saying the guy just said wes
anderson i just said i forget what his
[ __ ] name is
wes anderson's name dude you don't know
anybody's name no that's not true mr
ticketman
the human walkie-talkie mr tecamay i in
my when i had him i made him i didn't
make him but he was one of those
teachers who was who were cool he was a
cool guy actually and he let us pick
it it wasn't like i had to be mateo
oh okay i could we could i was crystal
ball yeah yeah i was zoro
okay wow and he thought it was funny and
every time i would raise my hand and he
would he would call on me and he'd go
oh yeah well you're like really bringing
me back with how he used to talk
you're right dude
hawaiian shirts yeah wow he was like a
very multicultural individual he was
he's probably dead now huh oh so
depressing well he's probably even he
was old then he kind of maybe he's 90.
he's probably dead yeah wow okay [ __ ]
bummer r.i.p dude you ruled yeah you're
listening to us up there in heaven if
you're or down there in hell
he might be in hell you know what he
might be in hell for what he showed us
[ __ ] you know how like sometimes a
teacher would just be like [ __ ] i i
just want to yeah like show you guys a
movie yeah you know yeah like i gave up
today yeah he showed us half
baked hopefully he's dead so now he's
not exposed and so uh
you get canceled for that [ __ ] out of
high school half baked dude hello
[Music]